I mean it really does boil down to the girls that get it get it
and the girls that don't talk shit and they're jealous about the other ones
like there's there
the easiest thing in the world is to get a man
the it is not a fucking flex to say you got a man
the real flex is to say you actually did something with your life
Ruth Bader Ginsberg
that's a fucking flex
she was married
do we know who the fuck he is
no Dolly Parton
she's a major fucking flex
do you know who her man is
no but she's had one for like 20 some fucking years
it's like a beautiful little love story
who gives a fuck about that
cause the real flex is doing something with your life
realising you're in a shitty situation and you gotta get out
realising you're worth more and you deserve more and you're gonna get more
the easiest thing in the world is to get a man
there are women in nursing homes that have been incapacitated for years
and end up pregnant
you know why
cause it's not hard to get a man
okay the girls I get it